with value men must earn their value  yeah oh wow  so women when a woman's born she she is  the most valuable asset  like so so a girl can be 18 and get  multi-million dollar modeling contracts  she could she could do only fans make  millions like she is a valuable asset  beauty is currency  that's why you see at political protests  women always take off their clothes  because that's the best way to get  attention is a beautiful woman  and men  there's a large proportion of men that  are invisible under the age of like 25.  and but if they focus on money muscles  frame and game by the time they're 35  they can get girls left and right  like jeff bezos right  i mean that's not i don't know what he's  doing with that one but  yeah that's the perfect example because  no one is looking twice at jeff bezos  when he's 18. but you know now he's  built up to be a billionaire he's got he  can screw whoever he